And everybody, this is Dr. Cutters.
Again, we're going to talk about some of the possible toxicity
testing that we may be performing in your initial workup.
And if there are positive things, we might
ask that you run again after three to six or nine months,
depending on what we're doing.
We want to see changes in this testing over time.
So again, we're always asking the question, why?
We're trying to dig to root causes.
Again, I don't think if you just ignore that piece,
it's to our own peril.
So we were trying to dig to root causes
and discover as many possible reasons why we have a disease.
I just think that's the best way of ultimately dealing with it.
So some of the labs that we're going to do
are to test for different toxins.
So you will most likely be getting a kit from mosaic diagnostics.
And this is a urine sample kit.
So you're going to get some a kit where you're
going to measure your urine.
You're going to get all the details on how to do that.
And just follow the instructions.
You don't need to register the kit.
We have already registered it for you.
So just go right into following the instructions
and collecting the sample.
This will be urine sample first.
Some other things we're going to do, saliva sample.
And the cheek swab is obviously a cheek swab sample.
But from mosaic diagnostics, mostly,
to begin with, it's going to be a urine sample unless we
do a stool sample.
But start with the urine sample kit.
Follow the instructions.
Regardless of what kit sample that you get
to follow the instructions for collection, you can do that.
At home, you don't need to go anywhere.
So the first test we're going to talk about
is the Tox Detect Kit.
And that's part of the urine sample kit that we run pretty much
on everybody now, because it's going
to test a bunch of different toxins.
And I literally just took a screenshot of an example test
here showing positive toxins with all these big names.
You don't need to know what the big names are.
They're chemical names.
I mean, we're exposed to things in our environment
that our ancestors were never exposed to.
These chemicals didn't exist.
They're made in a factory.
And they're put into fertilizers and pesticides
and herbicides.
And plastics and just a zillion different things
that we have in the first world have come
accustomed to making our life simpler, better, more productive,
et cetera, et cetera.
But it's also made our life much more toxic.
Now, in the initial part of the results that you get back,
and I don't worry getting ahead of ourselves
because we're talking about some results here.
But the initial part of the results
it'll show a list of the high results.
Anything in red is the highest.
Yellow is still high.
Green is where we want to be, where
it's a safe parts per million in our urine.
If it's higher in the yellow or red,
we're exposed to a lot of poisons
that we need to get rid of them.
Remember, our level of toxicity currently
is equal to our level of exposure, whether we breathe it in,
whether we absorb it through our gut
because we ate it, whether we absorb it through our skin,
we got it through some barrier, right?
Some bodily barrier got through into our body,
into our tissues, into our cells.
So our level of toxicity,
and it is given second to the day,
is equal to our level of exposure
might as our ability to get rid of it.
So that's where we want to look at genetics
and look at our detoxification pathways
to really look at our ability and the speed,
the rate at which we're able to get rid of poisons
that we're exposed to.
We're all going to be exposed to,
whether you think you're eating this perfect diet
and living this perfect lifestyle, sorry,
it's a shocker for a lot of people
who say they've eaten organic for 20 years
and have never let anything bad cross their lips.
You're still breathing in this stuff when you walk outside.
This is everywhere.
These poisons are everywhere
and your ability to get rid of them is really the key.
How well can you get rid of them?
Now you could go and dig down in these reports
and it gives you a really nice readout
of where you could possibly be exposed to these things,
but quite honestly in the toxic test,
it can drive you a little bulkers
because the truth is you can't get away from them.
They're everywhere.
You cannot live this perfect life
where you're not exposed to toxins.
It just doesn't exist.
So it really gets down to grabbing onto these
getting out of our body,
supporting our detoxification pathways
because remember, anything that gets inside your body
and if you're not detoxifying it,
it's going to be pushed to the extracellular spaces.
The extracellular matrix,
it can go inside the cell intracellular
and it can damage organelles of the cell.
It can damage the nucleus of the cell
and if it does so,
it can cause the cell to go into rapid replication.
That is what cancer is.
So we got to get these things out of our body
as best as possible.
We're going to be continuing to be exposed to them.
So we got to be supporting those detox pathways
and supporting the exit of these things.
Obviously, I think it's beneficial
to read some of this detail in your report
when you get this back
because it could go, you could kind of scratch your head
and go, huh, maybe I got it from whatever.
You know, I grew up in a smoke,
you know, tobacco smoke home
or I grew up in this, you know,
I worked in this paint factory or whatever.
There's some things in your past you can't do
but some things that you're currently doing
or in your future, you could make different choices.
So I think there's benefits to understanding exposure
even though you can't always change that.
Another test that we may do on you is a test for glyphosate.
Glyphosate are the component of an herbicide
that is the most widely used herbicide on the planet.
So you know what that is, bear makes it now
since they bought non-santil
and everything in less it's organic
is this herbicide in it.
So roundup is the herbicide that we're talking about
and it goes by different names as well
but glyphosate is everywhere.
Matter of fact, even if you're only eating organic,
there's probably cross-contamination of glyphosate.
So a lot of people are surprised
when they see their glyphosate levels are high.
It's like, how can my glyphosate levels be high?
I'm just, I don't eat, I don't even eat out.
I only eat organic.
Well, even organic food is cross-contaminated with glyphosate
and the truth is all these chemicals
that we're talking about have a half life
of about 15 million years.
So even if you were exposed to these 20 years ago
doesn't mean they're out of your system.
So getting them out of your system,
supporting the detoxification pathways,
he lady them is going to be key
to keeping you healthy in the future.
Another test we may run on people
is a heavy metal test.
Now, I personally don't think these are as accurate
as possible because they're, but it's the best we got.
So there is a perfect way to measure heavy metals
in our body.
But this is a great simple test,
you're advised to see some levels of heavy metals
that we do need to deal with.
Again, heavy metals, you get those,
where do you get them?
Aw, everywhere.
So again, these can cause all sorts of problems.
They can be causing cancer.
They can be causing neurological issues.
They can be causing Parkinson's,
a major cause of Alzheimer's dementia.
We want to know what we're dealing with
and what we need to do to get these out.
So there's other tests that we may do through this.
I have another video on just the microtox tests alone
and the genetic test alone and some of the other tests.
So watch those as well.
But when we get those, these results back,
we're going to go over them.
So we're going to talk about them.
So but I want you to watch this video
so you kind of get an idea of what we're going to do.
So we got to go over them and go,
okay, here's what you got right now.
We got to pull this out.
And so I may tweak your current protocol.
So initially, before we get these results back,
you'll probably already have your protocol binder.
That was done from the CheekSwap testing.
Now it may have come up in the CheekSwap testing toxicity.
So I may actually have you on what you need
to pull these things out.
Now the testing gate got us some specifics
in what we're dealing with.
I may have to add something.
Many times they don't have to add any other things
to help support this,
because it already came up with the CheekSwap test.
But at least we're going to get into some measurable data
that we can then re-measure.
And make sure that A, we're doing our job
and getting these pulled out of your body,
or B, you're not currently exposed to stuff
that, if your current exposure is higher
than you're ever going to be able to get these things out.
You're done, you're going to do.
You're just going to be poisoned.
So you have to look at current exposure.
So that's what we're going to look at through all of this.
And toxicity testing is a key component
of what we do as far as really getting down
to some brass tax of causes.
I think it's essential.
I think it gives us a good idea of moving forward
and how to make better decisions in our life as well.
So watch the other videos on the other testing as well.
I think that's going to help you understand it.
The more you know, I think the more you can prevent disorders.
And you can help your family members too
share these things with your family members
and your kids and your grandkids and things
so they don't end up in the same predicament.
All right, God bless.
We'll see you at the next video.